boa tarde
[Aplausos]
cores sabores e valores
boa tarde para todos e todas presentes
estou muito feliz não está nesse espaço
participando desse momento um evento a
nível global com a gente fala sobre
ciência fala sobre drones fala sobre a
nossa cultura local fala sobre os nossos
valores fala sobre ciência ela sobretudo
aquilo que o homem pode fazer para
transformar o meio ambiente ou ambiente
seja para as coisas boas ou para as
coisas ruins
o momento é um misto de emoção e um
pouco de tristeza também está nesse
espaço de partilha de saberes
pra mim é muito legal porque eu fiz
parte da construção dessa escola
no final do ano acho que em 2008 ou 9
estava no no if junto da reitora saber
lidar dentro desse projeto de expansão e
nós pensamos esse formato de escola e
pra mim mas melhor ainda por se tratar
de ser a escola criada no meu distrito e
guarulhos falar sobre isso é muito legal
porque segundo ela estudos em guarulhos
é hoje onde se tem o maior número de
negros
então é uma uma parcela da população que
carece de uma atenção maior por questões
históricas por questões ligado à nossa
cultura
nós estamos falando sobre é um povo que
veio de um outro continente
quando a gente fala à áfrica para muitas
pessoas se é refere apenas a um
continente mas se esquece que é ali são
praticamente 52 países ou 53 professores
têm mais certeza sobre isso não posso
falar com os países são de forma exata e
foram é mais de r eram negros para
campos de mais de 20 países
principalmente da pa
che da orla do oceano é atlântico do
outro lado e falar sobre esse povo em
especial
vieram aqui por conta de um é algo muito
importante que ontem o chico com
provável ele estava no arquivo público
ontem em palestra sobre o é açúcar
a vinda dos negros para que foi para
trabalho a gente não veio aqui pra fazer
a gente não nós não temos aqui para
turismo como é aqueles negros que foram
que é aquelas pessoas que vão para as
praias do caribe passear né
éramos reis éramos princesas eram os
nobres tínhamos a nossa religião
tínhamos a nossa cultura
tínhamos os nossos saberes e tínhamos os
nossos sabores
aqui chegamos para trabalho trabalho
duro trabalhar na lavoura canavieira na
semana passada dia 13 a gente não
comenta muito sobre isso porque o dia 14
foi um dia mais difícil para os negros
nós vamos chegar à parte das comidas sim
mas só pra lembrar como é que foi o dia
14 de maio dentro desse espaço aqui
chamado guarulhos onde era o maior
quilombo de campos
toda essa área que atrás proprietário
dela custódio diz no meio-campo custódia
por seu nome custo da publicidade de
pedra o maior quilombo que campos teve
campos hoje tem em torno de mais ou
menos 10 a 15 comunidades de quilombolas
comunidades remanescentes de quilombos
o que é um quilombo era um conjunto de
pessoas que não eram apenas negros
tinham brancos tinham índios que pessoas
que não queriam ficar né debaixo de um
sistema que ele primava de ser livre se
tem algo que nos faz mais é pra mim
assim ser humano é sinônimo de ser livre
agora quando você vem pra um espaço
contra a tua
vontade né pra ficar é escravizado né
uma grande parcela de homens e mulheres
negros brancos índios ou não decidiu
sair da área urbana que nós vamos dar
mas sempre para o quilombo para os
quilombos do emberg aleluia cambucá
conceição do em breve vamos falar sobre
esses quilômetros porque esses foram os
quilombos certificadas pela fundação
cultural palmares um órgão em brasília
que faz todo um estudo para ver se
aquela comunidade preenche os requisitos
para serem donos desse título quilombola
porque têm leis específicas que regem
esse povo sua cultura os seus hábitos
mesmo sabendo que é falar sobre
quilombos em campo é muito difícil
porque o conceito de quilombola é algo
que muitas vezes as próprias pessoas que
lá residem dentro desses km eles não se
aceitam como quilombo é pela mudança da
religião pela questão da terra enfim já
que falamos sobre terra não tem como
falar sobre o que eles comiam que é isso
que nos trouxe aqui se tratar de um povo
que estava praticamente em uma floresta
né pra eu gosto de olhar o imbé como
sendo uma grande floresta um lugar
belíssimo mesmo de cachoeira de muita
fruta para quem conhece lá é um clima
muito bom toda vez que eu vou lá eu
sempre penso em voltar então eram
hábitos alimentares simples comer banana
pequenos é é animais não é gado cadu que
não era dele
o gado que era muitas vezes dos senhores
das terras e vou falar dá ênfase a um
prato que é muito importante para aquela
região toda que é o próprio chamado
cantam cantam o que é é um purê de
banana verde com uma carne bovina hoje
utiliza se muito a carne seca porque a
carne seca é uma carne que ela dura mais
tempo então precisava ter o que é uma
tecnologia mesmo que muito rústica para
que é aquele alimento permanecesse em
conserva 11 por mais tempo eu estou
assim é um pouco tenso hoje porque
preciso falar sobre isso né minha amiga
francesca que também é chefe
o filho dela morreu ontem ele um
bebezinho zion né
eu até dei a minha parcela pra ele pra
pesquisemos evento na área de
gastronomia então tá assim doeu em mim
ela está vindo do rio agora com ele pra
gente colocar o o corpinho dele lá no
num espaço que merece para ele então eu
vim aqui porque eu tenho um grande
carinho pelo marcelo de um nome do
aristides beethoven e pune pessoas que
levam o trabalho muito é a série quando
eu quando fui lembrado por esse pouco
tempo lá pelo menos pra dar é a minha
parcela e falar que existe em quilombos
em campos
eu tenho um blog onde eu posso todo o
conteúdo do que a gente tem feito ao
longo dos quatro últimos anos né eu não
vim aqui para falar sobre receita dos
pratos com que os pratos estão sendo
mostradas ali o chefe que trabalham
comigo estão ali os alimentos estão ali
as cores
só não temos os sabores aqui não porque
é muito estranho pra gente que é chefe
de cozinha está em um espaço onde não
tem
as panelas diz costas aqui porque quando
eu vi aquela cerâmica
eu falei gente pelo menos ele já está
mostrando algo que faz parte da cultura
do negro por incrível que pareça o negro
também trabalhava cerâmica
o primeiro ato de ciência que eu entendo
assim que o homem parou e pensou que foi
criar é o fogo mudou praticamente é a
nossa forma de viver
os nossos hábitos os nossos sabores né
geral fogo né aquecer uma cerâmica pra
lá está é cozinhando foi alguma algum
mostrado ali os tipos de ingredientes os
tipos de temperos é usados quando ela
quando a gente fala sobre comida de
quilombo a gente não fala sobre comida
afro brasileira que é praticamente mais
comum para o nordeste onde utiliza é
azeite de vender a nossa comida de que
lomba que ela é composta de menos de 10
ingredientes porque era é as coisas que
eram disponíveis para aquele espaço da
floresta banana em miami
tal bicho é pequenos animais não têm
assim azeite de ervas finas dó de outros
países porque eram negros fugidos
pessoas que estavam saindo do meio
urbano a qui das grandes fazendas por
dentro da mata
então assim eram é pratos que não tinham
é aquele glamour todo como a gente fala
sobre os pratos franceses próprios
ingleses e italianos
o que a gente procurou por meio do nosso
projeto cores sabores e valores trazer a
cozinha dois quilômetros para dentro de
uma escola como essa equipe já fiz lá no
campus centro oficinas oficinas na uenf
num é arquivo público em toque pra quê
com o objetivo de preservar a cultura de
um povo o povo negro que essa escola
esse modelo de escola profissional é bom
lembrar que foi projeto de um presidente
que era negro uni-lo peçonha aqui de
campos
então dá pra gente poder falar sobre
comida em um evento de tecnologia de
ponta porque eu fiquei aqui olhando os
drones ali voando tenho dois filhos
ernesto e bernardo ficam fascinados
público
o drone eles gostam de carros celular
tablet ele joga o tempo todo o professor
eric estava falando aqui é agora pouco
de celular eles ficam o tempo todo no
celular
se não tiver um break uma pausa para ele
eles ficam jogando é o tempo todo e eu
gosto também que eles participam comigo
de momentos como esse eles conhecerem um
outro lado da família deles porque a
gente vive o extremo a minha família
descendente de negros meus tetravós
foram escravos aqui em campos
curioso da fazer da usina do queimado e
é a mãe deles é filho de portugueses que
são proprietários de grandes extensões
de terra onde planta se é aço é cana de
açúcar então se eles são filhos de uma
grande mistura em campo então é muito
mais fácil para eles conhecerem os
hábitos da comida portuguesa mas eu
procuro mostrar quais eram os hábitos
dos meus avós que são coisas é talvez um
pouco mais simples mas que tem muito
sabor
eu gostaria muito que num outro momento
a gente tivesse aqui uma grande mesa que
diz porte com todos os ingredientes para
a gente poder preparar todos esses
pratos que estão passando lhe preparando
o cantão preparando canjiquinha
preparando é a carne moída preparando
uma grande maquete e esse foi um
trabalho muito brilhante do instituto
dagaz o estudo do rio de janeiro fez um
mapeamento dos nossos quilombos aqui são
cerca de 38 quilombos no estado do rio
de janeiro certificado pela palmares e
deu e
fez essa obra que é um livro brilhante
em todas as oficinas nós temos
trabalhado os quilombos de campos nec
londres que tem uma história muito rica
e seria muito legal se vocês pudessem
conhecer os quilombos de campos neto a
cachoeira eu creio que o imbé tem um
potencial turístico enorme né não dá pra
gente é esquecer as nossas belezas
deixar de conhecer uma parcela de
pessoas que ainda vivem de forma simples
num tempo de tecnologia talvez eles la
paz em com menos problemas como esse que
o eric falou agora pouco de tecnologia
de dormir menos pelos hábitos saudáveis
alimentação com menos sódio com menos
olhos se for olhar tudo aquilo que que
foi mostrado ali
os pratos são pratos de aspecto simples
mas são pratos que têm sabor são pratos
que têm história pratos que é o que está
muito em voga hoje quando se fala sobre
a biomassa que é bom para o textinho
trabalho que tem fibra então né algo que
os negros já comiam há muito tempo a
banana é algo que está presente nos
hábitos alimentares dos povos à cruz
brasileiros é algo que faz bem para a
saúde
então assim é algumas coisas que hoje
são vistas como novas pra gente já são é
práticas que alguns povos que estão
distanciados do meio urbano ainda mantém
talvez nem por isso que eles sejam mais
saudáveis que nós da área urbana que
consome tanta coisa que não é saudável
que é muito sódio muito óleo na coisas
que não são legais para a gente poder
sobreviver
fico muito feliz por esse momento aqui é
em saber que
ainda existem pessoas importantes que se
importam com outros seres humanos que
num evento como esse que brilhante que
está indo hoje para diversos países no
globo todo tem gente vendo a gente agora
podemos saber que em campos dos
goytacazes uma cidade que foi a última
cidade a uma das últimas a abolir a
escravidão alguém sabe aqui porque no
nosso brasão tem um gorrinho vermelho
mas que passou ali alguém viu a bandeira
de campos até no banner do evento hoje
tem a bandeira dos estados unidos do
brasil a bandeira de campo está ali né
alguém sabe exceto professora alice diz
alguém sabe porque a nossa bandeira tem
um símbolo de junho um gorrinho vermelho
de novo vai abrir a bandeira para a
gente ver essa é a bandeira de campos
dos goytacazes é o nosso brasão muito
bonito né
na bandeira de é campos quando fala
sobre os negros é pelo menos eu só
consigo lembrar de dois momentos de
coisas que não são muito legais
o pelourinho e se nossa bandeira de
campos é um barrete frígio é muito comum
tem um personagem do nosso folclore que
utiliza né alguém saci pererê ano
pelo menos é o que um amigo passou pra
mim marcelo é bem conhece uma das que
essa cidade tem esse gorrinho porque era
pra mostrar para os outros povos que
aqui tinha escravos livres mas isso não
era é a tô me corrigisse o erro nessa
fala agora é a parte do açúcar da cana
de açúcar um dos países que mais
forneciam engenheiros para a gente era
inglaterra
então por isso que surgiu aquela
expressão pra inglês ver
então para ter uma relação de comércio
onde
envolvia a presença do negro precisava
mostrar que aqui tinha escravos livres
daí o nosso gorrinho é algo assim eu
ficar possível gente esses barretes
infringir querer saber que era o nome né
então né não
a relação comercial que envolvia a mão
de obra escrava negra e cana de açúcar
os ingleses pra vender pra campo só
podia vender se aqui houvesse esses
povos livres só 1 45 para falar sobre
isso em outra coisa sobre o pelourinho
no centro em frente à caixa econômica no
instrumento de tortura e repressão cores
sabores e valores
[Aplausos]